[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentandoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
el presidente de Ucrania
anunció que los servicios de agua y
electricidad están siendo reconectados
progresivamente Pero al menos 20
regiones del país continúan afectadas de
acuerdo con kiev los bombardeos de Moscú
son los responsables de los cortes
los diputados de la asamblea nacional
francesa aprobaron una resolución a
favor de consagrar en la Constitución el
derecho al aborto se trata de la primera
medida en una batalla legal que busca
adelantarse a posibles retrocesos en
materia de derechos de la mujer
la comisión económica para América
Latina y el Caribe advirtió que más de
200 millones de habitantes de la región
vivirán en situación de pobreza para
finales de este año de ellos al menos 82
millones estarán bajo el umbral de
pobreza extrema las alarmantes cifras se
producen en medio de la desaceleración
económica la alta inflación en el
territorio latinoamericano
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos inicio en Ucrania porque el
presidente abuelo de michelinsky informó
que los servicios de Electricidad y agua
están siendo gradualmente reconectados
tras los bombardeos rusos del miércoles
que según lleva afectaron
infraestructura crítica el mandatario
señaló que al menos 20 regiones del país
continúan afectadas por los cortes entre
ellas kiev el harkis previamente la
estatal de energía ucraniana ucranergo
preciso que la reactivación del servicio
de agua es la más urgente y la primera
en la que se está trabajando seguida de
la calefacción y la energía Generalmente
el drenaje de aguas
mientras suministramos electricidad la
infraestructura crítica también
proporcionamos agua y calor la situación
de la electricidad sigue siendo difícil
en casi todas las regiones nos estamos
recuperando gradualmente del apagón cada
hora restablecemos la energía más
consumidores la situación más difícil se
encuentra ahora en la capital y en 15
regiones
continuamos en Ucrania desde Catalina
Gómez Ángel enviada especial de Franz 24
nos da más detalles de lo que se vive en
la ciudad en medio de los cortes a los
servicios básicos
a pesar de los trabajos y de las
carreras de las autoridades ucranianas
parte del país continúa sin electricidad
esta noche en la capital kiev según las
autoridades el 60% de las viviendas
todavía no tienen luz eléctrica Aunque
sí sea restablecido el servicio de agua
y en Odessa donde nos encontramos la
tercera ciudad del país la situación es
más o menos similar si pueden escuchar
un poco se odian las plantas y es
bastante interesante porque solamente
algunos sectores donde hay edificaciones
gubernamentales tienen ya restablecida
la electricidad esta calle que está al
frente mío la tiene pero si nos movemos
metros más Allí están sin electricidad y
esto ha llevado a que se operen decenas
de lugares donde las personas pueden ir
a cargar sus celulares especialmente en
estos restaurantes o locales que tienen
plantas eléctricas si las autoridades se
han pedido a esos sectores que sí tienen
electricidad que por favor reduzcan el
consumo lo mínimo posible porque la
infraestructura no está soportando
mayores consumos durante estas horas
mientras que las autoridades hacen todo
lo posible por restablecer otra vez el
servicio en todo el país después de ese
ataque masivo de las fuerzas rusas en el
día de ayer en el que 70 misiles fueron
lanzados contra Ucrania 51 de ellos
fueron interceptados pero el resto
atacaron infraestructura energética
bastante importante que tiene el país en
estas circunstancias desde el día de
ayer por las autoridades han dicho que
esperan que mañana ya la situación
vuelva a normalizarse sin embargo vemos
mucha gente en la calle en este momento
aquí en odesa tratando de huir del frío
de sus casas y también de buscando un
poco de lugares donde conectar sus
celulares
el consejo de derechos humanos de la ONU
aprobó este jueves una misión
independiente para investigar la
represión en Irán durante las masivas
protestas que se desataron tras la
muerte de la joven masa mini que han
dejado al menos 300 muertos Teherán por
su parte sostiene que una injerencia
extranjera es espantosa y vergonzosa
tensión y cruce de acusaciones en Suiza
la sede del Consejo de derechos humanos
de Naciones Unidas en Ginebra fue este
jueves escenario de la división entre
los países occidentales e Irán en una
sesión de emergencia los representantes
de los países miembros aprobaron crear
una investigación sobre el deterioro de
los derechos humanos
de la fuerza Debe llegar a su fin
los viejos métodos y la mentalidad de
fortaleza de quienes ejercen el poder
Simplemente no funcionan de hecho solo
agravan la situación ahora Estamos en
una plena crisis de Derechos Humanos
unos 50 países encabezados por Alemania
e Islandia presentaron una moción ante
el organismo internacional para
investigar los presuntos abusos del
gobierno revolucionario islámico iraní
contra los manifestantes quienes llevan
más de dos meses en las calles en
protesta por la muerte bajo custodia
policial de la joven maxam mini quien
antes fue detenida por la policía de la
moral por llevar mal puesto el teslam la
República islámica de Irán lamenta
profundamente que el consejo de Derechos
Humanos se ha abusado una vez más por
algunos estados arrogantes para
antagonizar a un estado miembro soberano
de la ONU está totalmente comprometida
con su obligación de promover y proteger
los Derechos Humanos reducir la causa
común de los Derechos Humanos a una
herramienta con fines políticos
un grupo específico de países
occidentales es espantoso y vergonzoso
según la ONU la situación en el país es
crítica y el endurecimiento de la
respuesta de las autoridades ha causado
más de 300 muertes en los últimos dos
meses y dejaría alrededor de 14.000
arrestados todo ello mientras Teherán
acusa a sus enemigos extranjeros de
orquestar unas protestas que han calado
en todos los estratos sociales y suponen
el desafío más grande para el régimen
desde la revolución de 1979 en otras
noticias la asamblea nacional de Francia
aprobó un proyecto de la izquierda para
inscribir en la Constitución el derecho
al aborto es la primera etapa de un
largo proceso que continuará ahora en el
senado donde la iniciativa no tiene una
gran acogida
con un recuento de votos de 337 a favor
y 32 en contra wof festejo en la cámara
baja del parlamento
instituciones los legisladores votaron
el jueves a favor de consagrar el
derecho al aborto en la Constitución
Francesa en lo que podría hacer un
cambio histórico para el país la
propuesta fue presentada por el partido
de izquierda a la Francia en su mesa que
señala que la propuesta es para
protegerse de una regresión
[Aplausos]
ese Orgullo y esta emoción son
compartidos por todos hoy porque creo
que con esta votación la asamblea
nacional está hablando al mundo Francia
está enviando una magnífica señal a
todas las mujeres de nuestro país pero
también del mundo entero
la votación se registró como reacciona
los acontecimientos actuales en Estados
Unidos después de que el tribunal
supremo anulará en junio la histórica
sentencia Row contra wave Aunque el
aborto en Francia se despenalizó en 1975
no hay nada en la Constitución que
garantice estos derechos lo que sigue
preocupando a muchos activistas a favor
del aborto
los prohibidos están muy presentes están
organizados a nivel europeo a nivel
mundial en Francia podría ocurrir lo
mismo por supuesto en el contexto
internacional actual invitamos
el aborto podría ser cuestionado aquí
por lo que hay que consagrarlo como un
derecho fundamental
la resolución es el primer paso de un
largo proceso legislativo la propuesta
debe ser aprobada ahora en el senado de
mayoría conservadora e incluso podría
someterse a un referendo a nivel
nacional la comisión económica para
América Latina y el Caribe advirtió que
el 32,1% de la población total de la
región que equivale a 200 millones de
personas vivirán en situación de pobreza
para finales de 2022 de acuerdo con el
organismo unas 82 millones de personas
además quedarán bajo el umbral de
pobreza extrema los responsables del
informe destacan que la desaceleración
económica y la débil recuperación del
empleo tras la pandemia sumadas a la
inflación en alsa no solo profundizan la
crisis sino que la prolongarán se
enfrenta una crisis social prolongada y
urge abordarla
en particular lo que llamamos una crisis
silenciosa en educación para evitar el
riesgo muy real muy real de una
generación perdida Entonces tenemos esta
cascada de shows externos que incluye y
que ha producido una desaceleración del
crecimiento económico desgraciadamente
esta era una desaceleración que ya venía
desde el año 14-15
y que fue impactada mucho más
negativamente por la pandemia los
confinamientos
se cumplen seis años desde la firma del
acuerdo de paz entre el estado
colombiano y la extinta guerrilla de las
Farc en los actos de conmemoración
participaron integrantes del partido
FARC y madres de víctimas asesinadas
entre otros involucrados en el conflicto
que pidieron que la paz No se olvide y
que los acuerdos se implementen el
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez aseguró estar muy alentado por
el compromiso del actual gobierno
colombiano de regular esfuerzos en la
aplicación de la cuerda
de batallas por la implementación
podemos afirmar con certeza que el
acuerdo de paz de la Habana firmado aquí
en este teatro a posibilitar y brindado
las herramientas sociales y políticas
para abrir los espacios a la democracia
en Perú camioneros y agricultores
sostienen al menos 14 bloqueos en
diferentes rutas en protesta por el alza
de los precios de los combustibles y la
escasez de fertilizantes en ese país de
acuerdo con los reportes oficiales la
mayoría de los bloqueos son mantenidos
en la zona andina en el centro y sur del
país se cumplen ya tres días de cierre
de vías principales lo que ha comenzado
a generar inconvenientes en el comercio
y el turismo las regiones de tacna
Arequipa cusco puno ayacucho ancash y
piura son las más afectadas por los
bloqueos el Gobierno ya tiene ya los
puntos Como por ejemplo el tema del
combustible el tema de la sutran el tema
de bueno de la rebaja de los peajes el
tema del Puerto Seco de los carros
extranjeros al ingreso al Perú y tema
Bueno del tema del combustible del
contrabando los presidentes de México y
Ecuador Andrés Manuel López Obrador y
Guillermo lasso respectivamente se
reunieron en la capital mexicana en un
encuentro que calificaron de productivo
pero que no permitió el cierre de un
esperado acuerdo comercial entre esas
naciones los mandatarios señalaron que
el pacto Aún se está definiendo ese
tratado comercial es clave para que
Ecuador pueda ingresar como miembro de
pleno derecho a la alianza del Pacífico
que actualmente integran México Colombia
Perú y chile
cambiamos de tema en luanda capital de
Angola del presidente de república
democrática del Congo Félix chisekedy y
el jefe de la diplomacia irlandesa
participaron en una reunión de mediación
para encontrar una solución diplomática
al conflicto entre los Rebeldes del
grupo armado m23 y el ejército congoleño
al final de las negociaciones se alcanzó
un pacto sobre el cese de las
hostilidades pero un día después de su
firma el acuerdo no convence a todas las
partes en el conflicto que arrasa el
este de la República democrática del
Congo los jefes de estado de África
Oriental creen en las virtudes de las
diplomacia las media jornada de
conversaciones los presidentes de los
países de la subregión acordaron una
solución al conflicto entre el ejército
congoleño y el grupo Rebelde m23 el
ministro de asuntos exteriores de Angola
anunció los términos de la resolución
hoy en la Cumbre se decidió lo siguiente
el cese de las hostilidades en general y
en particular los ataques del m-23
contra las fuerzas armadas de la
República democrática del Congo a partir
del viernes 25 de noviembre de 2022 a
las 18 horas
pero el m-23 no estuvo presente en las
negociaciones y no se siente obligado a
respetar el acuerdo el grupo armado
quiere negociaciones directas con el
gobierno congolenio en goma la capital
de la provincia kibu Norte en el este de
la República democrática del Congo los
habitantes están a las puertas de los
combates y desconfían del acuerdo
algunos incluso han manifestado su
rechazo hacia la comunidad internacional
a la que acusan de apoyar al gobierno
ruandes que a su vez es señalado de
apoyar a los Rebeldes
a la comida internacional
exigimos que la comunidad internacional
en su conjunto pidan los jefes de estado
ruandeses y ugandeses que retiren
urgentemente sus combatientes camuflados
bajo la etiqueta m23
uganda por la agresión contra la
República democrática del Congo durante
más de 25 años
Un día después del anuncio del acuerdo
la calma sigue siendo precaria en la
línea del frente a unos kilómetros al
norte de goma otra cuestión que sigue
sin respuesta es la de los desplazados
que huyen de los combates según la ONU
más de 50.000 personas se encuentran en
condiciones extremadamente vulnerables
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos que nos hayan
acompañado y los invitamos a continuar
con nosotros que ya llega a Paula
Jiménez con toda la información del
continente asiático en Así es Asia feliz
noche para todos
[Música]